>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
SUNDAY IN AMERICA WE ARE
GRATEFUL YOU JOINED US THE
SITUATION AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER CONTINUES TO SPIRAL
DOWNWARD.
NO MATTER WHAT WORD THEY USE
AS AN UNSTABLE OR CRUCIAL TIME
BUT COULD BE MORE CRUCIAL THAN
THE SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS MORE
CRUCIAL THAN KNOWING WHO WAS
COMING TO THIS COUNTRY AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT COULD BE MORE
UNSTABLE THAN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN MAKING A DANGEROUS
TRIP FROM OPPRESSIVE HEAT WHAT
COULD POSSIBLY BE MORE
UNSTABLE THAN POLITICIANS
PREACHING FALSE HOPE TO
DESPERATE PEOPLE TO SCORE
LOCAL POINTS WERE DOING WHAT
IS THE SINGLE HARDEST THING
FOR POLITICIANS TO DO?
WE DECK EIGHT AFTER DECADE.
YOU ARE LEFT TO WONDER THERE
IS ACTUALLY CONSENSUS AMONG
YOU.
THERE IS CONSENSUS AMONG MOST
OF THE PEOPLE.
NOT FULL AGREEMENT ON EVERY
DETAIL WE WILL NEVER HAVE THAT.
NOT EVERY SINGLE PERSON IS IN
AGREEMENT.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE THOSE WHO
PROFIT FROM DIVISION AND ANGER
AND DISUNITY.
AND SOMETIMES WE JUST
DISAGREE.
THERE IS A BROAD CONSENSUS.
AND WHERE THERE IS CONSENSUS
THERE SHOULD BE A SOLUTION.
AND YET, NOTHING HAPPENS
BECAUSE THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
NEVER TRANSLATE INTO
LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
IT IS ALMOST AS IF THE
POLITICAL ADVANTAGE SOME
ELECTED OFFICIALS PERCEIVE AND
HAVING THIS DEBATE YEAR AFTER
YEAR OUTWEIGHS THE DESIRE OF
THE PEOPLE TO HAVE REASONABLE
LOGICAL FINALITY.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR FINALITY.
A SOLUTION, SOMETHING THAT CAN
LAST LONGER THAN ONE EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO THE NEXT.
MOST AMERICANS BELIEVE A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY BECAUSE A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRIES ENTITLED
TO KNOW WHO IS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
YES ITS NATIONAL SECURITY.
YES IT MAKES ECONOMIC SENSE.
BUT EVEN MORE FUNDAMENTALLY A
COUNTRY HAS A RIGHT TO
MEANINGFUL BORDERS AND HAVE
THOSE BORDERS RESPECTED AND
HONORED.
IT'S ACTUALLY WHAT MAKES YOU A
COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOT A PLANET OF NOMADS
WE ARE A PLANET OF COUNTRIES
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
WAY TOO LATE AND WITHOUT A
WHOLE LOT OF CONVICTION
FINALLY SAID DON'T COME.
THAT'S HARDLY PROVOCATIVE TO
TELL PEOPLE NOT TO MAKE A
DANGEROUS TRIP ON NOTHING BUT
FALSE HOPE.
IT IS NOT PROVOCATIVE TO TELL
PEOPLE TO STOP TRUSTING
COYOTES OR CARTEL MEMBERS.
THE TEMPLE SIMPLY SAY DON'T
COME VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WAS
CRITICIZED BY THAT ELEMENT ON
THE FAR LEFT REALLY DO NOT
BELIEVE IN BORDER SECURITY OR
BORDER INTEGRITY SO WHERE ARE
WE?
IF WE HAD A SECURE ORDER AND
SECURITY IN OUR VISA PROGRAMS
I THINK HE WOULD SEEK MOVEMENT
TO THE NEXT LOGICAL STAGE,
WHICH IS PROVIDING LEGAL
STATUS FOR THOSE WHO WERE
BROUGHT HERE AS CHILDREN
BEFORE THE AGE OF LEGAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU MIGHT EVEN SEE MOVEMENT
AMONG THOSE WHO ARE HERE NOW
UNLAWFULLY BUT WHO HAVE
OTHERWISE FOLLOWED OUR LAWS.
AND THEN YOU WOULD SEE FURTHER
MOVEMENT TOWARD THE LEGAL
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM WHICH
SMARTLY BALANCES ECONOMIC
REALITY WITH OUR COMMITMENT TO
FAMILY AS THE FOUNDATION OF
SOCIETY.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE BORDER
SECURITY.
THERE WILL BE NO MOVEMENT
UNTIL THAT INDISPENSABLE
PREREQUISITE IS MET.
IN FACT, NOT ONLY DO WE NOT
HAVE BORDER SECURITY, LAW
ENFORCEMENT BELIEVES WE MAY
ACTUALLY BE HEADED IN THE APP
OPPOSITE AND WRONG DIRECTION.
WE HAVE SEEN REPORTING ON MEN
SHOWING UP AT THE SOUTHERN
PART OF CRIMINAL HISTORIES
INCLUDING SEXUALLY ASSAULTING
CHILDREN PRODUCING AN INCREASE
IN CERTAIN DRUGS CROSSING THE
BORDER JUST AS WE ARE FINALLY
BEGINNING TO SEE SOME LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE OPIOID
STRUGGLE.
WE ARE EVEN SEEING INCREASING
CARTEL ACTIVITY ON OUR SIDE OF
THE BORDER.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE DEPRAVITY
IN PERSON, IF YOU WANT TO SEE
ACTS OF INHUMANITY, YOUR GOOD
CONSCIENCE CANNOT EVEN
CONTEMPLATES, IF YOU WANT TO
SEE THE WORST THINGS YOU HAVE
EVER SEEN, THINGS THAT WILL
MAKE YOU QUESTION WHETHER
THERE HAS BEEN ANY MORAL
EVOLUTION AT ALL, LOOK AT
THESE CARTELS.
THEY ARE SADISTIC, BUT THERE
ALSO OPPORTUNISTIC.
THEY CAN SENSE THE WEAKNESS.
AND THEN THEY EXPLOIT IT.
BORDER SECURITY IS NOT ONLY A
COUNTRY'S RIGHT, IT IS YOUR
RIGHT TO KNOW WHO AND WHAT IS
COMING AND GOING FROM THIS
SOVEREIG